I'm Veronica keeper of time I've guide  the destiny of the realms but my works  perfection has been tainted by Ravens  actions i amused all those who disdain  their current course of history by  merging past and present we may draw  allies empire in a new era will your out  world armies defendant  the total cost we have common cause  solving this temporal crisis and in  defeating shall calm  I will have my Scouts truck shall car  can't someone anyone explain to me what  the hell is going on right I've been in  the future for a whole hour and I  haven't seen one Jetta not one  [Music]  [Music]  Elder Gods the realms are in crisis  every being erased in a temporal fine  hanukkah's key and gaining control of  her alas only then x momentum be  restored we've got to take out another  realms are me now before Liu Kang can  bring it here  [Music]  [Music]  as my strength gathers the new era draws  ever closer  [Music]  [Music]